le revenant sur les nouvelles mesures
sanitaires annoncée par québec ce soir
avec la docteur cécile tremblay
microbiologiste et infectiologue au chum
à montréal dr tremblay bonsoir dans ce
moment alors est ce que ces mesures sont
suffisantes pour éviter la catastrophe
appréhendée dans les hôpitaux
je pense que ça m'apparaît tout à fait
appropriés dans les circonstances
est-ce que ça va être suffisant on va le
voir au cours des prochains jours et des
prochaines semaines mais je pense que
c'était un bon pack le gouvernement
avait à faire oui parce que ce que
disait monsieur d'ubs ministre de la
santé c'est qu'on connaît pas encore
vraiment l'impact réel de mitron sur les
hospitalisations sur la gravité de la
maladie en fait on a des études récentes
qui sont sortis aujourd'hui même qui
nous viennent d'angleterre et décosse
qui semble indiquer que au micro serait
car pour 40% de moins de chance d'être
hospitalisé avec un étron qu'avec la
variante delta ce qui est une bonne
nouvelle ce qui voudrait dire que on se
retrouve dans les modèles de projection
delienne esprit qu dans le scénario le
plus favorable mais le scénario le plus
favorable nous mener quand même une
augmentation des hospitalisations à la
mi janvier qui était soutenable pas au
système voyant une autre étude ou six
qui nous viennent d'afrique du sud qui
nous apprend qu'un mois après la
détection de variants au micro le nombre
de cas est déjà en baisse le nombre de
contaminations est déjà en baisse alors
est ce que vous dites c'est de bonne
augure l'étude britannique à ce que
l'étude sud africaine ou ci est ce qu'on
peut est ce qu'on peut voir un peu de
lumière au bout du tunnel avec ça je
pense qu'on peut voir la lumière au bout
du tunnel en fait ce que ces deux études
le disent c'est que une chance qu'on a
été vaccinée parce que la double
vaccination dans les tubes en angleterre
indique et corel avec la protection
finalement contre la maladie seibert
donc les gens qui ne sont pas vaccinés
en angleterre avait le même taux
d'hospitalisation qu avec delta donc ce
que ça nous dit c'est si on va chercher
notre troisième dose qu'on n'augmente
encore plus la protection contre
l'infection on va commencer à voir une
décroissance des cas
après le pic qui va arriver probablement
en janvier et on va avoir une
décroissance dans un contexte où la
majorité des québécois vont être très
bien protégé avec une troisième dose de
vaccin donc oui ça devrait nous donner
espoir et ça devrait nous encourager à
garder à suivre les consignes qui nous
ont été données parce que c'est un
restreignant les cas maximum on a va
chercher le troisième dose de vaccin
qu'on va arriver à ce résultat donc un
souper de noël à 10 personnes ça vous
fait pas trompeurs
mais à dix personnes en notant que les
gens soient vaccinés en autant qu'on
essaie de pas éviter des gens qui sont
vulnérables qui sont émis nos compromis
des personnes âgées en ouvrant les
fenêtres
je pense que ça peut se faire ça veut
pas dire qu'on est obligé de faire un
super à 10 ans ici on peut faire un
super avec juste sa bulle familiale
c'est encore mieux mais au moins ça
donne un peu d'air frais à la population
qui en a bien besoin voilà dr cécile
tremblay merci beaucoup